after that crazy genv finale after that awesome
Loki episode 5 after the Invincible season 2
premiere we finally are getting the thing we've
all been waiting for the echo Spider-Man 4 Echo
that's what we're waiting for echo echo I'm
joined by Echo right now we're letting John
sleep get a lot of shade for this already for
some reason and we can take guess's as to why
but you know what I'm going in with an open
mind or you I am I'm a big David Mac fan he
co-invented Ekko so I'm excited to see what this
is this is tvma oo yeah man isn't that awesome
that's exciting I didn't know that changes kind
of the mind frame around some stuff we've heard
ladies and gentlemen leave a like like like
like like like let's see what this looks like
Maya Kingpin right away the first line I
think is Kingpin I see everything that you
are always have full Kingpin nice it's gritty
Kingpin all right tvma Kingpin blood in the
white suit oh my God this actually feels
violent don't be
afraid this feels like the Kingpin we
know yeah this is not like Hawkeye at
all so far that jump a little
loving the sound design so
far you have so much pain in you you you e so
much rage rage rage that you can't contain it
yo this trailer is working for yeah this is
a great trailer and the guy from H Hawkeye
right punished oh yeah there's actual violets
here yeah they shot the guy in the head oh my
God a little Daredevil T is that
Daredevil yeah you and I are the
same oh the connection between her and Kingpin
so who's the
monster I thought that was a great is that what
say your profile to tvma to stream there's like
a setting to get to Echo uh whoa holy crap
wow I you know there's been a lot of morbid
cynical thoughts surrounding this show you
know what this made me think of there's been
so many people who have been really making www.
reject Nation shop Thrive this year my God guys
thank you so much we got shirts like citizen
gang over there the one Koy is rocking right
now the real regets tickets we also got Child
Protection Services we got space babies of the
Galaxy we got who watches the influencers or who
influences the influencers I mean it's Watchman
inspired that's where I got confused we got Last
of Us inspired teas we got Ahsoka inspired te's
we got Loki teas it has been a successful year
and it's personally my favorite way to support
the channel so thank you guys so much for going
out of your way and checking out that shop coyi
uh yeah man I just got to say that I thought
that I like the character-driven narrative here
between her caught and sort of this darker phase
in her life and watching how her development and
excuse me guys it was just non-stop editing all
day yesterday so I'm getting my brain working
right now yeah watching the development between
her and Kingpin seeing sort of the crossroads
she's at between being a hero and succumbing to
the darkness but you're watching how she became
like kingp like doing it through visual physical
representation of it yeah my favorite part about
it especially with Kingpin was I was one of those
people who was like I wasn't a big fan of the way
he was portrayed in Hawkeye and this feels more
akin to how Vincent deno's portrayal was in the
Daredevil show I really enjoyed all the the I
think it's Chu CH choka inspiration of the Indian
Nation I like seeing a the vibe it's probably the
people we've seen the least on screen like like
Native Americans are probably the people we've
had the least groups of represented in a in a
big property so I'm like excited to see cuz that
like violence looked hardcore the culture that I
don't know a lot about like I'm I'm Cherokee
somewhere down the line it's cool to be like
learn that like we had with this Marvel like I
got to learn more about Muslim culture through
the comic and then even more through the show it'd
be cool if they get to touch on that through this
show it's because they're trying to get in with
Martin scorsi who just play the long they did
K of the flower Moon which is a different when
they agre with that they went through like what
characters do we have that are Native American
let's get Scorsese to direct secret War yes I
was pleasantly surprised by this trailer man I
thought it would just be like a cheese fest I
was afraid this trailer would be the things
I didn't like about Hawkeye which tended to
be really really rough editing a Cheesy is tone
kind of undermining the more serious elements of
the characters I love like I I really love Hawkeye
and when they let him be a family man that worked
I really loved Kate Bishop when they let her like
lean into that like um fighter but also like being
young that worked but when they undermine both
of them and especially like we both had Kingpin
problems it really didn't work so I wasn't all
that excited for Ekko not because of Ekko but
because of Hawkeye so the fact that they're kind
of making this shaped more like the Kingpin show
is interesting because clearly that's the draw
versus like character like Eko which isn't known
as well but that's kind of how you get characters
that aren't known as well in that that's kind of
how Comics work here's a character you know and
love here's a guest starring role obviously the
show is called echko but I thought it was smart to
have the lead of the trailer not the lead of the
show pull you in by having Kingpin as like your
your eyeline right so you get your familiarity
and it's more the familiarity of Daredevil's
tone and then you also get the surprise for
us of the violence the white suit with the blood
splatter the insane stunt work that one shot of
Daredevil I was afraid this would be okay let's
like catch up on Ekko maybe a lot of flashbacks
when I saw two minutes I was like it's going to
be like a minute of Hawkeye and then maybe like
they'd sprinkle in a Cambio and then at opening
with Kingpin at first I was like oh this kind of
like it's not the Echo Show it's the Kingpin show
but then I was like wait they're connecting these
two people through this narrative through this
violence through this situation and then the
audience is going wait I am interested because I
am familiar with these characters so I thought it
really worked yeah well a big part of it is that
it it just doesn't feel like they were utilizing
Kingpin to get some guest St cameo in there
it's about the relationship between them he's
the coad from the story not just the the way they
utilize exactly like it's about the influence of
the relationship that she had with him and also
the dichotomy of the situation because it is her
father in a sense right like we had I forget some
of the details in the specific of show with her
actual father but this is her father figure still
someone who raised her you also got the complexity
like yeah he she shot him and even though he lost
his eye he still doesn't want her dead like he
seems like he still really cares very much for her
in that one scene and the other part about it too
that I I loved is I was not interested in an Echo
Show we've both been like well that's out this
year but this made her seem like a very compelling
character in a way that made me go yeah I I'd be
down to actually see this character the the things
that that have me concerned are all the behind the
scenes stuff that right right the fact they're
putting it out one day but you know that could be
just like viewer reception not of necessarily the
show but of people like us going like do we want
this it could be reactionary to not the content
but to the feedback from Hawkeye you know what I
mean yeah yeah this is maybe how you get people
to watch it by having a Kingpin uh focal point
having Daredevil Cameo having but if you do it in
the day you're going to have people talking about
all those things maybe that's the idea I love
the framing of a lot of this a lot of these uh
flashback shots what's funny about it is it kind
of has the cinematography of the Daredevil movie
it's like they flashed back to Daredevil the movie
not the show it look it doesn't it look kind of
look like the like 2000 like Marvel Fox Vibes like
there's definitely I was like all right so is the
Daredevil great in this Charlie Cox or Ben thank
God youit felt when they showed the inside I don't
know what it was but something about the inside of
the car poov I was just like new medals C it was
it's the cinematography of it that really feels
I think it's Mark stepen Johnson it definitely
feels like like that but I think there's a lot of
really cool symmetry in these shots a lot of cool
framing I don't know if the sound design is just
due to like I feel like they'll probably do some
of the cool sound design with going in and out
of ekko's perspective because she is uh because
she is deaf so you would and they did that in
the Hawkeye show too right yeah I think they
showed more violence in this trailer than it did
in moonnight yeah yeah and I mean it being tvma
is pretty neat and maybe that's one of the reasons
they decided to dump all the episodes at once that
it just seems like such it's just such a weird I
also it's what the last cheek show like I think
Iger came in and so cap 4 is like half cheek
half Iger era if I'm remembering correctly I
think this is the last full chiic maybe they're
just like let's end this era in 202 2024 clean I
think it's a weird ass time jary they I think it's
a weird ass time to release this trailer because
of what it's being sandwiched in between yeah I
thought this was like December for some reason
but it's January so they didn't need to rush it
I'd be I I I'd be lying if you know I I gotta say
like I thought this was a better trailer than
both Marvel's trailers yeah yeah and it showed
more of what the I haven't seen the Marvels this
felt like I know more of what it's about whereas
the Marvel trailers are just like there's stuff
happening and they got Beasty Boys it's a solid
trailer and I think like just with their Disney
plus experience maybe the first episode will be
like good and then I I'm just kind of hoping it
doesn't dip halfway the P ultimate episode will be
not story driven but it'll have stuff happen and
maybe they'll punch at the end yeah I just hope
it doesn't Meander something like that that's the
one thing even Visual and tonal wise I could see
it happening where it's a it's like really there's
like gravitas it's really serious it looks cool
but then maybe it becomes a little perfunctory
and and stuff they're like all right well they're
walking into that building there they go I could
see I could see a bad version of this but for a
first trailer I got to say it really won me over a
lot I'm shocked this is maybe the biggest surprise
trailer of recent memory definitely yeah I was
very cynical about it that's honest that's honest
I did not want to wake up to do this after working
so late but this looks the most different of uh
expectation to reality but also from um what we
got the last time we saw a character to the new
a th% man all righty guys what did you think about
this Echo trailer were you as pleasantly surprised
by this as we were um people are probably mad at
us for even liking the trailer confirming that
we're watching it even acknowledging that we are
here Greg I'm sure there are people who are also
mad because we came in a bit cynical and then we
liked it and they're like why were you negative
and before the people that commented 10 seconds in
are like why are you negative people that waited
to the end are like why are you shills and now
the sence I'm going to say it's going to piss
off a lot of people that are fans of this remind
me of The Equalizer you know I mean totally like a
ponderous violence and like what violence does to
a person in stuff yeah and then really using like
your your Keen sense of awareness and using the
like environment around you for like the tone of
yeah they gave me equalizes so yeah deal with that
comment board sorry for talking so much what are
you talking all right talking to Loki fans let me
get this up and I got to try to take a nap and I
forgot to mention we're going to be doing a a live
stream tomorrow for those who care who made it
this far hey you're still watching Invincible Loki
news all the stuff tomorrow live be here see you
guys